[Musique]
corps de chasse bannière et to pour une
messe haute en couleur fidèle et membres
de confrériie célèbre Saint-Vincent en
la collégiale Saint-Denis un rendez-vous
incontournable pour perpétuer la
tradition la convivialité de T les gens
quiimportant comme not Paro c'est
important d'être tous les dimanches et
puis d'entourer effectivement les
confreries locales je P de faire le
patrioinere moment for de la journée
l'intronisation chevalier Jacqueline
Catrou vigneronne à Limeray et un visage
loin d'être inconnu celui d'Émile codins
professionnel du vin très actif
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux
j'aurais jamais parié ça jamais mais
honnêtement aujourd'hui je suis assez
fier F d'être ici de con de pas
connaître le vin il y a 5 ans et
aujourd'hui de pouvoir le transmettre
aux autres qui connaissent pas le vin
donc on a vraiment changé de de regard
et voilà d'être sur cette scène là
devant devant justement des générations
que je ne connais pas la plupart des
gens je les connais pas ici mais par
contre ils me connaissent ils savent ils
savent ce que j'ai pu faire et j'ai un
immense respect pour toutes ces
personnes qui sont présentes ce soir
l'arrivée de ce jeune homme de 26 ans
c'est un nouveau souffle pour
l'institution qui entend bien moderniser
son image les confréies comme je dis
toujours faut qu' se réinvente parce que
c'est vieillissant et tout c'est des
traditions qui se sont un petit peu
perdu et donc ça c'est important d'avoir
des jeunes comme ça vraiment qui qui
sont vraiment en phase avec le métier
comme je disais qui mettent les mains
dans le Cambou de bonheur et tout et
puis qui aime ça et qui savent surtout
en parler
en 56 ans d'existence la commanderie des
grands vins d'emboise a investi environ
4000 chevaliers de véritables
ambassadeur de la vigne et du vin rab
aurait pas rêvit mieux